what suggestions do you have for writers
on developing character so for me you
know Hunger Games is no good without
caddis that you like you like Katniss is
the end harry potter is the is the end
like you have to have a great hero or
your products don't work obviously
doesn't matter how good your story world
is doesn't matter how good your your
your plot is you have to have a
character that that people that people
care about and so when you know your
your you're talking about the individual
journey of the character and how to
develop the character I think personally
it goes back to so box I think it goes
back to that thematic that you're trying
to to create and develop and if you know
what you want to say then you will
naturally know how to develop your
character and so because typically your
soap box will be be something that your
character needs to learn and if you know
you you want to teach people how to how
to you know overcome disabilities and or
or or you know if you go back to the
Joseph Campbell thing about like you
know achieving or embracing your destiny
right so neo story the matrix for
example neo story is I think his so box
that message of his character goes from
you know somebody that that embraces
their destiny and they have this
tremendous destiny that they achieve
that he achieves at the end really
interesting character development
happens there but his starting point is
him not him needing to find out the soap
box is he's at a you find him in a place
where he he doesn't feel like he has any
purpose any death any great destiny at
all he's stuck in a cubicle has a
meaningless life and so his starting
point there is is a great starting point
because if you then when he achieves the
soap box death II in the movie that's
what creates the the development so I
think you know any good screenwriter is
going to tell you when you develop a
character its cooled I think adding a
high concept to that character I think
it's cool to you know make that
character interesting in a lot of
different ways but if you
motional arc of the character needs to
be routed and what are they learning
what what's their deficit at the
beginning and how do they realize that
soapbox toward the end and that's what
gives them the emotional journey and I
think if you tie that to that basically
back to the a and B story right like you
have your your a story which is the
physical goal they're trying to achieve
so in taken the a story is all about how
do I get my daughter back but then the B
story is is basically how do i how do I
become a good dad and it's sort of the
emotional deficit that he has is that he
has in the beginning is what he learns
toward the end of the movie and so and
so it's tying those two things together
I think really makes the good character
development but but from a transmedia
perspective I think always understanding
how to give your individual character a
high concept and also give them
interesting looks and this is something
that like you can pull from from George
Lucas is that is that the Darth Vader
would not be as iconic if he was just a
dude in a robe right like I think
there's something about the about the
look of Darth Vader that makes him
iconic Boba Fett
you know characters that have
interesting dress interesting objects
that they have the the the costume
design I think goes a lot into what
makes a character interesting good the
Black Panther I think you know that like
the female warriors the way they were
dressed the way they looked I think that
added so much to the character and so
there's a a one of my one of my friends
in the transmedia community jeffrey long
he he always he always says that to have
an interesting character they need to
have an interesting silhouette and if
the more interesting their silhouette is
then the more striking and memorable
they'll be as a character and then you
know the more you do that then the more
yeah I think more story potential are
going to naturally have but I think that
you have the gas in the car when it
comes to character is what's their
emotional journey
what's your physical journey and you
know course they're starting important
how they how they end but then if you
could also layer in the high concept to
them and then add in like sort of an
interesting look with interesting
objects give them interesting secrets
that nobody else knows
I think the little things right like
that make characters awesome like I love
the fact that Indiana Jones is scared of
snakes like that's just a really like
small thing to add into the character
but super effective that gives that that
interesting character depth though
understanding like what are your
character is afraid of what's a secret
they've never told anybody doing that
sort of work
then then even if you never reveal those
things in your first story in a
transmedia world those are things that
you can kind of pick on and use this
jumping off points moving forward you
know I used the movie um quiz show
a couple times I you've realized I'm
going back like price twenty years but I
find that a very interesting look at two
characters sure one who's actually not
telling the truth but he's regarded as
the hero yeah and the other one who's
actually being honest and he's actually
in a tough situation being like
henpecked and told he has to make more
money but he's actually painted as a
villain sure and I just think it's a
very fine it's based on a loosely based
on true story but maybe talk about the
like what why are we perceiving Ralph
Fiennes his character as really the hero
this guy gets an applause from the
subcommittee or whatever and he's like
praise as this golden boy and John
Turturro is actually the bad guy yeah I
I think this is really interesting just
I think that is a commentary on culture
of how we root for certain characters or
don't root for certain characters I mean
I always the the a great example of that
is I think is Breaking Bad of you know
that Walt is doing bad things even after
he passes the point like a first you
justified is like he's doing it for good
reasons but then like everybody kind of
gets the fact that he's that he's doing
it he's Breaking Bad right and that's
the whole point of it but we're still
rooting for Walt the intent like we're
still rooting for a wall one of the most
derided like hated characters on that
show was his wife my people like people
didn't like his wife and she like you
know she was a good person that wanted
to do good things and and so she was the
good guy Walt's the bad guy but the way
we the way we cheer for them is is is is
flip-flopped
right I've forced Whitaker was I heard
an interview with him when he starred on
the shield if you remember the shield
Allen FX and
Vic Mackey one of the greatest TV
characters of all time he's a bad guy
he's a straight-up a bad guy but he's
the protagonist and and we root for him
the entire time Forest Whitaker is the
is the cop who comes to investigate him
he's the good guy
we we hate that guy we hate the
character and and it's just we flip-flop
going back to an old Johnny Cash
interview that I heard is he would talk
about how how when he was seeing Folsom
Prison Blues whatever he would when he
whenever he would deliver the line I
shot a man in Reno just to watch him die
crowds would roar and they they love
that line and and you're thinking why
would they like that like why did they
get excited about this character that
Johnny Cash is portraying shooting a man
just to watch him die this is a
despicable awful evil thing but I feel
like that's a testament to culture even
in professional wrestling circles right
I mean if you take it to that like Stone
Cold Steve Austin was a bad guy that
people loved because he was breaking the
rules I think it's just an interesting
commentary on people and how we we lean
in to to sort of the bad boy
bad girl we lean into those I mean I
think I think if you look at even the
superhero stuff today culture there was
a day where Batman and Superman were the
square-jawed wholesome John Wayne type
of heroes and superheroes today now we
love Deadpool and I think that's just a
commentary on culture and and how
culture shifts over time and you know
there was a time when the John Wayne war
movie was ruled the box office but then
in the Vietnam era like that begin to
turned up where we didn't want the
square jawed like you know son going
down to the background and like the
birds flying around and at the patriotic
music we didn't want that anymore we
wanted something else and I think I
think that's just a testament to culture
and testament to like the human
condition and the human like the the
human
the condition of the soul of the
audience is is and I think you know
we're trained as far as story we're
trained if you position someone as a
protagonist whether they're an antihero
protagonist whatever that so you you
almost remove the the hero villain
moniker if a great storyteller positions
a bad guy as a protagonist we just will
naturally root for them I mean if for
example in Star Wars they're like lines
of comic books that where Darth Vader is
the protagonist and you're rooting for
them him the entire time and he's a
mass-murdering magician and and you
still root for the guy because we're
trained to root for protagonist I think
that's just like hardwired into our
brains to where it makes perspective and
POV really super important important to
a storyteller understanding that because
naturally we root for the protagonist
whether or not or despite the fact that
they're that they're good or maybe
they're bad
you